hi ich bin Marie und ich bin heute von
einer Wohnung mitten in der Stadt auf
einen alten Resthof von 1850 gezogen
mein Freund ist auch mit eingezogen wir
waren bisher in der Fernbeziehung und
stürzen uns jetzt zusammen in das große
neue hofabenteuer wir haben erstmal ganz
provisorisch nur das nötigste eingepackt
für den allerersten Umzug und werden
jetzt erstmal für ein paar Wochen hier
renovieren bevor wir dann den großen
Umzug machen und das ist so ein
unglaubliches Gefühl jetzt endlich hier
zu sein und wir entdecken noch so viele
neue Sachen die wir bei den
Besichtigungen bisher überhaupt nicht
gesehen haben allein was ist hier
anschätzen in den schäumen zu entdecken
gibt schreibt mir gerne mal in die
Kommentare welche Themen rund um den Hof
euch interessieren dann kann ich nämlich
ganz viele neue Videos dazu machen